zach wheeler an era of 2.83 he's reached
200 strikeouts this year he's reached
200 innings this year as the phils try
to take the series from the orioles
1-1 swung on hit of the air right field
going back on at harper towards the
track he'll make the catch and austin
hayes retired there's a one two three
start for zach weiner he does so on ten
pitches yeah keegan aiken you know he
doesn't get a lot of runs 3.81 runs so
he got 93
by herrera and severino able to hold on
the first down of this bottom of the
first inning both men lean and can come
set 2-2
swing and a miss he got him in a
breaking ball
down and away rio muto chased it
so keegan aiken now one out away from
getting out of the center as he got rio
muto to expand outside the strike zone
no runs allowed the bottom of the first
it's first and third with one out two
balls two strikes
back toward the middle flagged down by
wheeler to second for one over to first
in time
crazy footwork by segora
to get himself centered to then fire to
first base in time the cannon of segura
aids in the turning of two man and a
great job by wheeler the ball almost
popped out the top of the glove but he's
done a nice job fielding that himself
and a strong throw orioles turned away
in their half of the second one in the
inning one man left austin hayes will
bat for a second time against zach
wheeler
swing and a miss
and hayes strikes out that's number
three for wheeler
2 34 on the year yeah yes he did it
does go around four strikeouts three in
a row for wheeler who got here in the
fourth
swag and a miss he threw some heat right
on by him and he struck out the side
four strikeouts in a row for wheeler he
has five in the game the mount castle
leads him first wheeler from the stretch
is austin hayes bats in a scoreless game
that ball is drilled to left field by
hayes a fair ball that gets to the wall
mccutcheon will grab it mount castle to
wave around third here's the throw he is
safe
and rio muto and the ball pop out of his
glove
trying to get hayes at third as austin
slides in untouched it'll be an rbi
double and the orioles strike first
against wheeler they lead it in the
sixth well you got a guy with a big time
fastball and a young hitter with a big
time bat speed you know we saw him do it
last night in extra innings
off with ian kennedy hit similar pitch
down the line and of course he's running
hard so is mount castle
nothing nothing ball game
like we said good enough speed to easily
score even though this throws a little
bit high might have been bang bang if
it's low it's not then he can't get a
handle austin hayes eric handhold as the
orioles have
given the phil's a little bit of a break
by getting aitkin out of the game
well andrew mccutchen went over two
against aitkin and now bats against the
righty handhold with two outs in a man
at first
out toward left center field mullins
going back it is gone
a two-run blast by andrew mccutchen
it's his 25th of the year
and the phillies have erased the deficit
and now leading two to one
you said get yourself one he got himself
he got himself one that didn't miss it
the pitch before i thought he had one
too and he kind of
rolled over it a little bit but that one
there he
that was
palm up palm down perfection look at
that wow
he knew it too
423 feet
cuts go scissors
to dusty's paper he's closing in on him
i hope he has a chance to catch him 75
runs batted in for andrew mccutchen
wheeler's done
six innings four hits one earned run
nine strikeouts he was great again and
now sam coonrod will take over the
phillies are seeking nine outs from
their bullpen and all of a sudden the
tying run is at third
and the go head run is at second
that ball grounded off the mound that
will get in a run gregorius goes to
first pick something out but mancini
ties the game bringing in martin after
the wild pitch gutierrez to third and
the orioles have struck back to tie it
at two now the richie martin base hit
you know ground ball up the middle and
then of course the walk to the eighth
place hitter and then all trey has to do
and not hit you know strikeout gets the
good count two and one good rod's trying
to throw something over the plate and
joe girardi will not let sam coonrod
face cedric mullins so satisfying inning
for the orioles they get a run against
[ __ ] rod they bring the go ahead run to
third and it'll be jose alvarado to face
cedric mullins pulled toward first
fearling is able to gather himself and
take it to the bag and the inning is
over one run does score here in a tie
game runners at second and third for the
phillies
segura hits one out towards center field
mullins this should be deep enough he's
under it beerling's tagging from third
the throw goes to third and the phillies
retake the lead
gene segora a sacrifice fly it's three
to two jt gets ready to stand in runners
at first and second
back toward the middle and into center
field to base it here comes miller
cruising home rvi single it's a two run
lead it's a 4-2 ball game castle tonight
is over two he's lined out struck out
and walked and scored
opposite way oh what about
wow
that was a fantastic play by matt
beerling
he had very little time to react hardly
any at all i mean that's a big strong
man at home plate to just hit that
rocket down there wow what a play the
trojans 2-2 pitch to severino
fastball groudon fair severino finds the
right field corner to bring in hayes
this one a long way out there and
severino will hold its second a run
scoring double for pedro and the orioles
once again slice into the philly lead
it's 4-3 here's pat valencia with two
outs and the tying run at second base
opposite way of base hit it to right
field
is coming home harper's throw to the
plate is on the fly
he's out at home plate
he had no chance to get to the dish
9-2 on the put out
the phillies hold on to a one-run lead
and chance of mvp as harper comes into
the dugout he and kennedy try to pick up
his ninth save into phil's uniform and
ryan mount castle is due up
and a high fly ball out to right field
harper's got room
and he makes the catch it's a can of
corn
and the phillies hang on and win it by a
final score of four to three
you